زلزال سوريا وتركيا المدمر احد اعنف
الزلازل في العالم واشدها فتكا منذ اكثر
من عقد
الكارثه وقعت فجر الاثنين السادس من
فبراير زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
ضرب مساحات شاسعه من جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا تسبب بصدع يمتد طوله لما يزيد على
100 كم بين الصفيحه الاناضوليه والصفيحه
العربيه مركزه كان على بعد 26 كيلومترا
تقريبا شرقيه مدينه نورداي التركيه
[موسيقى]
جميع سكان سوريا وتركيا شعروا بالزلزال
حتى الدول المجاوره لكن اثره المدمر تمركز
في شمال غربي سوريا وتحديدا في محافظات
حلب وحماه واللاذقيه وطرطوس وادلب اما في
تركيا فضرب الزلزال بعنف 10 ولايات وحولها
لمناطق منكوبه
[موسيقى]
بعد 11 دقيقه من الزلزال الاول تعرضت
المنطقه لهزه ارتداديه بلغت قوتها سته
درجات فاصله سبعه
وبعد ساعات وقع زلزال بقوه سبع درجات ونصف
الدرجه تلته هزه اخرى بقوه ست درجات في
فتره ما بعد الظهر
[موسيقى]
حصيله الزلزال العنيف لم تتوقف عن
الارتفاع بين القتلى وجرحه ومفقودين
ومشردين تجاوزت عشرات الالاف في كلا
البلدين عدا عن الاف المنازل والمباني
المدمره
منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان يبلغ 23
مليونا عدد المتضررين بالزلزال بينهم نحو
خمسه ملايين من الاكثر ضعفا
[موسيقى]